les travaux de la nouvelle piste
cyclable qui reliera la france à
l'allemagne au niveau de l'île du rhin
près de neuf brisach se poursuivre
jusqu'au 4 avril
l'aménagement de cette voie verte
constitue le chaînon manquant d'un
itinéraire stratégique reliant
l'allemagne à la piste eurovélo 15 près
de 600 cyclistes passent quotidiennement
sur cette route empruntée par quinze
mille véhicules une densité de
circulation qui représentait un danger
non négligeable pour les cyclistes
donc c'était c'était dangereux il
fallait traverser malgré les camions et
les voitures il fallait poser son pied à
terre et traversé la route et c'était
donc très dangereux pour passer en tant
que cycliste
il restait donc à réaliser un
aménagement cyclable sur le pont sur les
écluses un endroit très contraint est
très étroit qui permettait pas de faire
une pipe comme on dit de 3 mètres de
large mais avec l'accord de
l'administration concernée on a réussi à
dégager une
un espace piéton cycle de deux mètres un
peu inférieur à dieu mais très bon sens
grignote et ça nous oblige à réduire la
largeur de la chaussée à 6,50